tenemos aquí 7 por 10 a las 5 entre 2
por 10 al menos 2 por 2.5 por 19 ok son
números en notación científica que se
están multiplicando y dividiendo
entonces lo que queremos es encontrar el
resultado y expresar lo en forma de
notación científica y para hacer eso lo
primero que voy a hacer es simplificar
el denominador entonces esto es igual el
numerador lo vamos a dejar igualito 7
por 10 a las 5
y el denominador pues son un bonche de
números que se están multiplicando
entonces podemos reacomodarlos y hacer
las multiplicaciones en el orden en que
queremos por aquí tenemos 2
por ahora vamos a poner a este 2.5 2.5 y
después ponemos días a la menos 2 por 10
al menos 2 y finalmente ponemos 10 a la
9 por 10
entonces esto es igual voy a dejar el
denominador igualito otra vez
pero ahora voy a tomar 2 por 2.5 eso es
un 5 y se está multiplicando por 10 a la
menos 2 por 10 a la 9 ok ahora estos dos
números tienen la misma base entonces lo
único que tenemos que hacer es preservar
la base y sumar los exponentes entonces
menos dos más nueve eso es un 7 y ahora
si podemos separar estas
multiplicaciones que se están dividiendo
en dos pedazos gay esto es igual a 7
entre 5 y 7 entre 5 por 10 a las 5 10 a
las 5 entre 10 a las 7 10 a la 7 ahora
estoy aquí siete quintos después 1.4 y
esto de aquí pues tienen la misma base
de 10 el único problema es que ahora se
están dividiendo entonces hay dos formas
de hacer esto uno es decir ok tengo 10 a
las 5 entre 10 a las 7 pero uno entre 10
a las 7 es igual a 10 a la menos 7 y
entonces multiplicamos 10 a las 5 por 10
a la menos 7 y lo único que tenemos que
hacer como tiene la misma base es sumar
y nos queda 10 a la 5 - 7 o sea 10 al
menos 2 o decimos bueno ese camino ya lo
hemos hecho muchas veces ya sabemos que
si tenemos la misma base y se están
dividiendo entonces tenemos que escribir
la base pero elevada a la potencia el
exponente de arriba
no es el exponente de abajo ok entonces
nos queda 5 menos 7 que es menos 2
ahora la pregunta es esto estará escrito
en forma de notación científica como que
parece que si no pues resulta que sí
porque este número de aquí si es mayor o
igual a 1 porque es 1 punto y cacho
entonces si es mayor o igual a 1 y es
estrictamente menor que díaz entonces
esta parte está muy bien ahora además lo
estamos multiplicando por 10 elevado a
alguna potencia entera entonces si
definitivamente esto está escrito en
notación científica y es el resultado
digamos que simplificado de estas
operaciones